What do you see in terms of the way they fueled themselves?
It's like the biggest error.
Sticking to want one style of feeding regardless of the training style that
they're engaging.
And so MMA athletes,
they have to do high intensity training session strength and conditioning.
They have to be doing sparring,
they have to be doing pads rounds that are you crazy heart in every athlete.
Each one is going to have a different intensity relative to to to their body
type.
And so if somebody is doing pads,
it's a nine or a 10 out of 10 in terms of intensity and they're doing that fast
it or they're doing that without carbohydrates available to do that work.
They can't,
they can't a hit those training intensities repeatedly and then they can't adapt
as a response to that training.
So they in end up just getting slower and more beat up instead of faster and
more powerful.
So if they're doing high intensity,
we need to fuel the body in the specific way that supports that training effort.
And then the longer term adaptation to that bout.
Additionally,
if they're doing lower intensity,
we can adjust our fueling strategies based on what that dictates.
You know,
if it's,
if it's a kind of a base of aerobic training session or if they're doing skills
and drills,
we want to be feeding the body to adapt differently than if they're doing the
high intensity sparring strength and conditioning or pads or whatever that might
be.
So for every athlete we're looking at how their body uses substrate energy,
the energy that they're using,
the sub strait between carbs and fat at each of these intensities,
and then we also needed basic base.
We need to base our recommendations on where their body fits into the division.
If they're,
if they're 20% out from their weight division four weeks out,
then we're going to have a little bit of a more aggressive strategy
nutritionally because of weight becomes a primary factor.
If they're 10% out,
four weeks out,
then we're going to have a little bit of a different conversation than
prioritization around the fueling strategies and all of these conversations
integrate within our strength and conditioning program so that we're working in
concert and tying in the workload in into our own system as well as the,
the training load that they're engaging with.
Skill specific training.
Now when you vary the Diet that you give them independent dependent of the
workout,
what does,
what does that based on?
Is that based on a heart accepted science of carbohydrate versus protein versus
essential fat essential fatty acids?
Like how do you determine that?
So we,
we,
we use a philosophy,
a system called metabolic efficiency.
You could call it metabolic flexibility.
I've heard of call it as well.
And essentially the body will use different substrate add different intensities
and at low intensities and at rest the body can and likely should be adapted,
uh,
for our,
for our sports athletes to,
to fat at rest.
Now it depends on the sport type.
Again,
if we're a shot putter or if we're a 100 meter sprinter,
then we're going to be much more dependent on carbohydrates.
And really the creatine phosphate system,
we're not even getting into the glycolytic system.
And Duncan could talk a lot more about the energy systems,
but essentially we're,
we're reliant upon glucose and ATP for energy at those lower intensity births.
Right?
So to hit repeated Max or sub Max efforts,
we require blood sugar.
And without it,
we will,
will deplete our,
our initial stores.
And then we can't,
we can't,
we can no longer hit 90 or 95% of our Max.
We start hitting 80 and 70 and 60 and diminishing our ability to do these high
intensity efforts.
Now,
do you guys see anybody come in and try to fight on a Ketogenic Diet?
Because I know quite a few guys were doing that for awhile.
I know Bryan Caraway did it.
Matt Brown.
Yeah,
that's right.
He has fought,
but he,
he varies it,
I think he,
yeah,
well I talked to him.
I think he did one per pure,
and then he did,
you know,
he did the one where you,
you might take in 60 or 80 carbs,
but then you work them off to stay Kadijah.
I don't,
some of those guys like Zack bitter.
Um,
he's a ultra marathon runner.
He v he does eat ketogenic most of the time,
but then on days of big races he'll consume a lot of sugars.
Yeah.
And yeah,
and again,
I'll insulin sensitivity to,
yeah.
So essentially the more we could regulate blood sugar at rest and low
intensities,
then we can expand and to support the development of that kind of aerobic
oxidative system.
And by adapting to use fat as a primary substrate,
we're,
we're doing a number of things.
One,
we're balancing blood sugar at rest so that we can really limit the insulin
spikes and essentially adipose development.
Um,
in addition to really
driving the body towards the oxidative and,
or the OC state of aerobic system.
And then as we increase in,
in,
what we do is we assess how the body adapts,
so through the training intensities,
and we'll repeat that kind of on a monthly basis to see how the athlete changes
and then as they increase in the intensity of a training effort,
then we will adjust the ratio of fat to carbohydrates as,
as the,
as a fuel substrate.